why is transformation of the main
character important uh well I think we
go to movies really to see
transformation right transformation
means that the story had an effect it
the series of events that you've watched
it had some sort of consequence it had
an effect on the character that went
through them so that's one reason and
then I think also you know even if
nobody talks about it this way we sort
of we look for that transformation as
like
um sort of a inspiration or you could
call it a guide for for living a good
life right like it's this person went
through this experience and sort of came
out the other side uh can give you hope
it can give you a little bit of
um you know a guide guide on how to live
and be a better person but that's kind
of like what gives the story meaning in
the end you know how does transformation
relate to theme well I think that most
often we see the theme of the movie
through the character's transformation
so whatever that lesson is that they
learn from going through this whole
experience that's basically the theme of
your movie
um you know
the the theme is like the sort of
organizing principle of your story right
and everything connects to the theme and
kind of everything falls under the
umbrella of the theme and the way your
movie plays out proves the theme to the
audience and so a big part of that is
the way the protagonist goes through the
story and what happens to them how they
transform because of what they've gone
through so we see the theme the meaning
or that takeaway message of the story we
see that through the way the character
transforms most often
for some reason I'm thinking of like
Goodwill Hunting just popped into my
mind it's been many years since I've
seen it yeah the transformation of that
character yeah and kind of the theme
would be what just sort of I know you
said helped earlier yeah well I think
that it themes
um tend to fall into like a couple of
categories or patterns right um one of
them can be sort of Hope for
um living right
um and then another kind of category I
think is like there's Beauty in the
struggle right like themes kind of fall
into these different categories but
specific themes for particular movies
um most often I look to the characters
transformation or the lesson that they
learn to kind of understand what the
theme is
um in Goodwill Hunting it's been a while
since I saw that movie but uh I guess
let's see how does he transform from the
beginning to the end well so he's he's
angry he gets in fights he's got this
job that you know he's kind of looked
down on a pawn but he's definitely
smarter than and maybe some of the
students around him there and he
[Music]
um
meets a girl yeah I was gonna say I
think the lesson has to do with the that
big choice that he makes at the end
right so he he sort of learns over the
course of this story that he's not doing
himself or anyone else any favors by not
living up to his potential right
um again it's been a while since I saw
the movie so hopefully that's accurate
but um but I would say that you know
that if you look at his transformation
and sort of the key lesson that he needs
to learn or that he does learn by the
end of that story then that's kind of
the key to your theme I would say that
that lesson is basically the theme you
could reword it a little bit and then if
if if that's accurate say for for
Goodwill Hunting if the lesson that he
learns is
um you know life is about living up to
your potential for example I don't know
if that's true but we'll say that that's
the lesson he learns in Good Will
Hunting uh I would say that the theme of
the movie would be very close to that so
the overall message that that story
would send that you would maybe walk
away from the movie understanding is
living up to your potential is what
life's about or it's how to live a good
life is to to try to you know strive to
live up to your potential or what have
you what does the audience need to see
in each Act in order to understand the
protagonist transformation oh well um I
think the the transformation has you
know
it has an arc of its own so in the same
way that like the plot has a setup and a
build and a resolution I think the
characters Arc also has those those
parts so in act one we need to set up
that Arc by understanding what the
character needs right like what is their
deficit or what lesson do they need in
their life
um what sort of are they doing wrong or
how are they seeing the world in a way
that's not serving them and what effect
is it having on their life so we need to
see that they need a lesson and we need
to see sort of we need to understand
that they do need it and usually that's
by seeing some sort of negative effect
that not understanding that lesson is
having on their life right and then in
act two that's where we see kind of the
the the story of this Arc play out so we
need to see the things that he the
protagonist experiences in the story
sort of forcing him along that growth
Arc forcing him to realize the lesson
that he needs to get closer to accepting
it or to
um maybe the character is resisting
learning this lesson and the things that
he's going through are forcing him
closer and closer to kind of that
breaking point where he's going to
finally understand what he needs to
learn from this whole this whole mess
right
um so act two forces the the plot events
and the experiences that the character
has
forces him sort of closer to
understanding the lesson
that thematic lesson right and then in
act three that's where we get to see the
character
Embrace this lesson or not right in most
movies that we watch that have sort of
um Transformed Characters and Happier
Endings usually they accept the lesson
and embrace it and incorporate it into
the way they approach the world and then
that's that's how we see that Arc
resolve how does character lead to plot
oh well I think you can you can use
character to sort of lead you to figure
out plot by
related to character Arc right so
understanding
what lesson your character might need to
learn or what transformation you want
this character to have right
um this is sort of coming at it from a
like a meaning point of view instead of
a an external plot point of view so
coming kind of from inside the story to
figure out the plot so if you start with
character and you think about what
lesson do I want this character to learn
or what transformation can I imagine
this character going through that
interests me that can lead you to plot
because you know that the plot that they
experience needs to sort of create that
change in the character right those
events have to force that character to
learn that lesson so you can sort of
reverse engineer the plot from the
transformation that the character is
going through
um thinking about okay here's the
transformation that interests me I'm I'm
curious about a character who maybe goes
from being um you know an independent
single guy who's determined not to have
any any ties or or serious relationships
to being someone who is is committed and
you know surrounded by close
relationships with friends and family
right so that's his transformation just
for example
um if you're interested in a character
that makes that transformation then you
can reverse engineer the plot to think
about like well what kind of events
would force somebody to make that change
to learn that lesson and sort of
transform in that way
do you see that from time to time with
new writers that there's not a real
lesson
that that's that's learned with their
character and then having to go back and
rework it yeah I I do because I think
that
um not all not all the time but a lot of
uh newer writers and not even newer
writers a lot of Writers come that story
from interesting plot right from
interesting what-if uh situations that
are cool or fun
um and then you know developing the
character to go to go along with it and
there's certainly nothing wrong with
that I I think about story in that way
too A lot of the time
um but I think for newer writers then
the challenge is understanding that the
the transformation or the character
development side of the story is is
still needed is important right
um and you know we talked about earlier
that like writing a screenplay is really
getting a handle on lots of different
skills it's a bunch of different skill
sets that you sort of have to employ all
at the same time
um and I think character development
tends to be
one that maybe
um not for not as forgotten but gets
pushed to the side because you know the
plot is the thing that you know you need
to have right in order for your story to
for your movie to begin and eventually
end you know that you have to sort of
like work out the steps of the plot
um but character you can have characters
show up on the page and go through this
plot without making a change right and
you've still written you can still write
a complete screenplay that way right
um so then that's like another skill set
to master I think or to to learn about
um and so yes with newer writers I think
a lot of times uh not not even a lot of
times but often you'll see
a complete story and the story is there
um and maybe they know that the
character should learn something across
the the course of the story but they
haven't fully you know gotten every step
of that transformation kind of worked
out in there
sure so maybe too worried about just how
the overall story is and then not really
seeing this change in the character at
the end yeah and I think that for
um you know again because it's so many
skill sets it's it's not even
it's it's certainly not deliberate of
like oh I'm not going to worry about
character and it's also not
um I guess it's a very easy thing
because you're trying to juggle so many
moving Parts when you write a screenplay
that
um it's I totally understand
and not not maybe doing all of the
character development up front that you
could right so it's just part of the
rewrite process like you you go through
it many times and then hopefully you get
the character there too yeah hence the
second set of eyes yeah yeah exactly you
said there's so many skill sets to
writing a screenplay can you just
clarify what some of those skill sets
are yeah I just think you know it's we
usually think about writing a screenplay
as just it's just one thing it's one
story that I'm putting down on paper but
um you know when you when you try to
write a screenplay well you probably
eventually realize that there's
understanding structure there's
understanding plot and how to escalate
conflict there's understanding character
and character development uh theme and
how theme works with transformation
right and that's just kind of like big
stuff and then you also think about like
the on the page craft writing action
lines well writing dialogue well you
know like there's all these little not
little but there are all these different
skill sets that go into making a really
good screenplay
um and I think it's a lot more than
writers realize maybe at first when they
come at writing a script because you you
sort of you have an idea and you love
your story idea and you start putting it
down on paper and that's great I think
that's the way
you know the best way to learn is to
through experience and through trying it
um but eventually I think you know
anyone who's written a script or two
sort of realizes oh this is this is
harder than I realized it was going to
be because there are so many different
things that I have to be good at in
order to make the whole thing good you
know so if someone just erases a
paragraph
on page 68 it's going to change things
maybe you know on page 10 that they
didn't oh wait a minute I just realized
if I do that that's a major thing I have
to then go back yeah for sure
everything's interdependent
um and I think also you know this is
what this is what makes the rewriting
process so fun and so challenging is
that because
you can be good at one thing or have one
thing kind of figured out one area one
skill set or whatever
um worked out and still be struggling
with other areas and because they're
related you know they they will probably
affect each other
or you know
a lot of times like we were just talking
about character gets sort of short
shrift you know while we're trying to
work out the plot because we're there's
so much to think about in how do I
structure this plot and how do I
escalate the conflict and how do I make
sure that there it's logical from
beginning to end you know
um and so then in the rewrite you're
gonna have to bring that character
development kind of to the front of your
mind and pay attention to it as you're
rewriting it but yes everything's
interdependent and I think
um even when you have like
some of those skill sets really worked
out you you know the plot's great or
whatever when one of them isn't working
like say the character development or
say the dialogue you just haven't paid
attention to and it needs a lot of work
um
you know it it just it sort of you
realize how much work goes into a
screenplay how many different skill sets
you need in order to complete that thing
in a way that like can be appreciated as
a whole you know